[Music]
in game of tones news what's that swells
each Tommy
look it's close enough submitted by
Starcraft cafe I go back to the Game of
Thrones dark wrath it's a video game but
the Fox right or not a game of Thrones
cinematographer complaints that Battle
of Winterfell episode was too dark dark
as in tone or dark as in like oh no like
the color a lot of the blacks were
crushed so I only see the memes because
I did not watch it and all the people
are like Game of Thrones episode 3 and
be like a black screen and I'm like I
don't know what happened but [ __ ] them
don't watch unsubscribe to HBO you
[ __ ] complain well you know you
can't change the [ __ ] black on your
TV right I guess a lot of people are
complaining like the majority of people
they were watching it in a very well-lit
room or they were watching it on their
phone or their laptop and that's not the
way that the cinematographer intended
you're supposed to watch it in a dark
room in a dark room on your TV everybody
watches TV that way everybody not
everybody watched I watch I have to
watch shows in a black bag I have to
have a light on in the dark way to do
everything
and for Game of Thrones with the
millions of dollars they spent it's got
to be a dark room okay what that's the
point they should have addressed it in
the beginning of that yeah they should
put a disclosure on even in a dark room
though it was kind of dark
it was super - I don't think they
thought that people with that gun would
it might be most of a more of a
post-production thing because like he
did it was really dark it did make it
worse he didn't like it wasn't intended
for that so like I was like squinting
the whole time talks about game with
those that for me
so cinematographer was in HBO's video
compression of the episode decreased the
quality by a lot so that also added a
lot of pixelation just for that they
should give us another season give us
extra season 9 because you guys [ __ ]
come on man come on buy this season
wouldn't they know how to compress their
videos right it's been 8 seasons I get
it it was the first season even for this
like it like there should be no
explanation
cuz you still watched it anyway yeah you
still [ __ ] loved it and someone went
approve right because if you looked at
Twitter it was just how dope the episode
was so as a cinematographer what I would
have done was I don't care tweet was
pretty dope it was just a also worked on
about all the bastards
I love another great episode
way to pay your season 1 episode 3
though well there's bastard in there
just watch it burn her out she said it
look I watched episode 3 okay said it
sarcastically on purpose because
everyone listened to her except for you
Joe when she said it I said it off
camera yeah I am on episode 3 season 1
and it's taken me three weeks to try to
get through it it's hard to falling
asleep in the middle maybe she was
watching retired
I thought after watching a darkroom
close the shade that's the perfect
condition for sleeping you fall asleep
yeah every time is it like it's a
podcast every time the horses start
traveling I just get a little dispersed
scene in the cinematography sucked
no they either have really riveting
dialogue or their show in the landscape
and art direction is so much to dig into
it's just like medieval dad jokes no
it's like a king be like ah looks like
you put some weight on your belly and
he's like dude what are they supposed to
make you not talk to each other they're
friends episode I remember it's
mind-blowing cuz then randomly a dick
pops out like I have never seen a period
piece or penises fly seen dicks in a
period piece like that I don't really
like to watch period the first is really
hard to get through though because
season 3 because Casey's in season 3
right now and he was like all jammed you
know what's right it takes till season 3
he's really invested you see that watch
20 episode it was hard girl Casey has
been fighting watching Game of Thrones
for years and it took us going to
therapy I'm saying listen this is
important to me up you need to watch
this with me and the therapist is like
just do it for her man even I have
always been on the same page of life we
don't want to watch this see that's
that's what's hard is both of you don't
want to watch both of us are really
trying to get through it on the
therapists I did that first two seasons
was [ __ ] hard to get through that
[ __ ] is broth Thank You Bart
you're not gonna attack him how do you
know David's dead my love is you
attacked me in the McDonald's and on our
way to Vegas I was like it's so poor in
the first season she's like what'd you
say about Game of Thrones yeah yeah
tipples holding me back now I personally
offended Lee we love and then it was
like yeah it was hard and I'm like see
it's like they didn't really have like
the budget for the for season two so
like the way people hiked out like oh
the cinema taught the first season was
trash it looked terrible thank you
episode 1 my brothers and sisters are
[ __ ] a man
[Laughter]
yeah I almost straight up was like we're
gonna ban this from our house after they
killed the wolf I was so sad sweeps me
her name was Lily I know but it was all
sense of sports she could no [ __ ]
hitter cuts I liked Sansa now I don't I
didn't hate any of those characters
except for Cersei in the first season
because like I understand there cuz
they're kids they're super young you
know oh yeah yeah I can't even like just
wishful thinking oh I wish I was in the
Royal Court like how can you hate like
[ __ ] Tommen right like he's a brand
you know too many characters yes that's
why it's so hard to get through in the
first season because they go oh here's
this person here's that other location
so many like banners and different
houses and different characters I'm like
who the bucket scoop what another are we
watching it I'm like oh I thought the
later seasons are great because they
just killed half the character so now
you can keep up
boilers who cares like I didn't know the
only episode that I think that if it got
spoiled would have bothered me would be
the latest episode that came yup oh yeah
nothing else if it got spoiled not watch
anything because you need you cannot
know I just don't buzz where it's like
red wedding oh the red wedding though
I'm talking about I'm talking about damn
now that's the episode that got me
hooked on the show I think I think you
got to get there and on you'll start to
be invested episode 9 and Casey's right
now like episodes I coaster 7 I'm like
you can't watch episode night without
you see red wedding it no I told them
only you can't watch episode 9 without
me you have to so sick there's a cult
you guys aren't a cult book yeah when
are you to drink the kool-aid god damn
it I've been trying it really sucks very
sour grows on you it's like addiction
come on me the first episode dude I
don't even know how to that first
episode
you remember your first drink of alcohol
you didn't like the taste but I got Shui
stiffy you gotta wait until you're not
wasted yet you gotta get very severe
severe cold like I did and you have
nowhere to go
yeah that's the only way I could do it
that's the only way I watched it before
I refused you have to binge Game of
Thrones there's no way you can watch the
few H episodes so long - it's not long
enough Vicky will you have time you do
it it's pretty cool
you make time it's still kind of
confusing you definitely have to go back
and read up on certain things because
there's so much information so many
different houses so many different case
yeah and that's where the show becomes
really overwhelming I think it's really
slow though the first season oh it's
really slow how three seasons it feels
like two seasons of setup yes that's
what it ah yeah well then it's the but
it is worth it because you become
invested to a lot of characters I don't
think was law and I have a TD like crazy
and I don't I don't understand why
everybody [ __ ] yeah Samwell Tarly
[ __ ] that even in the latest episode it
only confirmed how much I hated him
because he's on the battlefield he got
five people killed in the castle less
people would've died this [ __ ]
was like well I killed a white Walker
I killed a thenn shut the [ __ ] up the
newest Lord Commander died because get
sick of slicing yeah that's it
Harley go home oh my god that's why I
like him cuz he pisses me off like Jon
Snow sees them and he was like I would
run away if I was on the battlefield and
I saw Sam I'm getting the [ __ ] out of
there I know he's a dead magnet looking
nice gonna go through my channel [ __ ] I
was watching the behind the scenes and
then others saying they put Sam on the
battlefield cuz since everyone by this
time is so heroic and such a leader
you're not gonna get a feeling of what
war feels like to the common person I'm
gonna get annoyance
yeah so they got
like the straight man in the middle of
the battlefield and that's how a normal
person I don't need that I wanted him
gone
or I wanted him dead I was laying I was
praying a knife would have went right
through his [ __ ] chest I was like
it's not even called straight Manning
it's called [ __ ] Manny oh good
even though way he stood up to his to
his dad was such a a [ __ ] way to do it
he that's why I like him I was the way
in the middle of the night he goes from
like yes I'm gonna take this sword yeah
yeah yeah what a [ __ ] way to do it you
know what I mean like everything about
him is so [ __ ] am I still your [ __ ] I
know I think that's why I like him so my
mother I know in the other when the
other dude Edie I think his name was the
one that died I was like dick on no that
wasn't it name dad his brother no tell
him about the new the new Nightwatch
dude that one oh that the new Lord
Commander
oh the he was a lord - man yeah yeah
give it to him cuz John was like he came
back and he was like I'm done give him
the [ __ ] the cape he didn't want to
deal with them cuz he just tried killing
his ass [ __ ] dude the guy that was
protecting Sam right yeah he got him
Nicky is so into this conversation just
moving like I like that guy a lot too
and I'm all like you should have died
you [ __ ] fat smart [ __ ] but it's
okay if anyone else are you thinking of
thrones this episode's gonna stop before
you 9% of people watch that we
everyone's in the Stone Age everyone
watches it no everyone is cooler but you
Nikki